alex you know i think it's time to get
our cowboy boots on what do you write
yeah
i think so go dust those off good
morning monica this is one of my
favorite things here in vegas
oh all the single ladies i think the
ladies yeah
better put some bling on those boots
because pvr has changed a lot they bling
out
and yes folks thank you guys so much
good to be here with you this morning
pbr returning to town this year after
taking a break from
las vegas y'all know it's because of
covid and for the first time in history
i'm so excited about this ladies and
gentlemen it is partnering pbr is
partnering
with the bill pickett invitational rodeo
they are celebrating black cowboys and
black cow girls and their contributions
to the west
i never knew growing up joining me live
to talk
more about this is oba babatunde from
the bill pickett rodeo and yeah y'all
seen him in hollywood on movies and all
that kind of stuff
and this is sean gleason he is the ceo
of pbr gentlemen good morning to you
thank you so much for being here
it's a joy to be here with you monica
all right let's get right into this pbr
the bill pickett invitational rodeo
coming together here in las vegas this
month
what can we expect from this very
historic collaboration gentlemen well
look at it
go ahead sean jump in sorry um we've got
a two-day pbr event planned friday
saturday and sunday we're bringing bill
pickett to uh
to mgm grand garden and the pvr
experience
and we're gonna broadcast the event a
week later on
juneteenth so we're extremely excited
and for both of you and mostly for you
sean because you're in charge of this
huge event you know vegas loves us you
guys have been coming here for so long
and i've interviewed the cowboys through
the years the champions as well
why was it important for these two
entities to come together at this time
in our culture
and what were the nuts and bolts of that
conversation
with organizers uh over i'll let you
start with that and sean
i want you to pick that up as well not
sean i'm sorry oba
over i'm sorry yes yes no of course no
well you know
it's if this is such an a historic and
monumental event
for a number of reasons as you laid out
monica i mean to have these two people
you know these organizations come
together you know the the bill pickett
wrote the invitational rodeo
it started in 1984 by a man named lou
basan and it was to educate
you know the world on on on on bill
pickett
who who created an event called well
that's how it was called bulldogging is
now known as steer wrestling and
and a lot of people as you mentioned
growing up didn't even know about the
aspect of black
cowboys and cowgirls and so to have
these two great
groups come together it's just a
historic and a monumental event and i'm
telling you
do not miss it we are going to have the
time of our lives right there in vegas
all right go ahead jump in there sean
what's your take
you know what cowboys were the first
melting pot in america
yeah black cowboys white cowboys
hispanic cowboys they all
uh convened in the west and started
driving cattle to the railheads
and uh you know so the the culture of
black cowboys in america
has been lost until lou brought it back
with bill pickett
and uh we want to do our part to keep
telling that story and celebrate black
cowboys white cowboys cowboys of every
color
i love that okay give us the details on
the fan favorites of the show
and tell us how you're dealing with
those you know who may be still
a little squeamish about covid
[Music]
well uh we've been conducting events
since last july
in front of fans july 10 of 2020 we went
back in front of fans we have
safety protocols in place that mgm
is executing and you know fans are safe
in our environment we've been
doing events we've done probably 40 or
50 events in front of fans we haven't
had
one issue of covet spread come on out
it's safe
we're responsible you know wear your
mask if you want to
but have a good time all right i love
that okay and i know
your fans you guys are such a wonderful
culture are fans going to be able to get
up close and personal for like selfies
and autographs and stuff with the
animals and the writers
well i certainly listen i'll be there
and i'll be looking forward to saying hi
to all of the different fans and you
know what a lot of people have
identified me from as you mentioned film
and television but there's also a number
of other celebrities that are also going
to be there
jim pickens jr from gray's anatomy is
going to be there he's a cowboy glenn
turman
who has a you know been in the game in
the entertainment for years reginald t
dorsey you know there's going to be a
lot of celebrities there
that are looking forward that are in the
culture of
the cowboy lifestyle and i want to say
that it is as
as sean mentioned it's a lifestyle it's
it is something
that we have been doing in terms of not
just
the fact of its horses and bulls and
those things that's great
but it is also a means by which people
live where they live
in harmony with other human beings and
that's one of the things i think we want
to promote and suggest to everybody
that's coming out and we look forward to
seeing
all right okay guys where can we get
more information if everybody wants to
get tickets because i know it's a family
affair i love this event so tell us
where we can get information
we can get information on pbr.com
at mgm's grant gardens website
um call me call over
you'll find your way there and gentlemen
before i close out and forgive me if i
get emotional growing up
i never heard about black cowboys and
black cowgirls
never learned about them in school from
k-12 and i attended a private parochial
school in detroit
the closest i came to knowing what a
cowboy
was was john wayne on television and now
i'm the mother of a 15 year old black
male
child and it is so important
that there is representation because it
matters
there's a history there that i never
knew until i became an adult
so from the bottom of my heart i really
want to say thank you
pbr sean and to the bill pickett
invitational rodeo thank you for coming
together because now my son
can tell a story that i wasn't able to
tell as a child
it is important thank you thank you
absolutely we look forward to seeing you
in las vegas
all right take care guys we'll see you
again soon all right monica thank you
very much
all right take care guys hey and don't
forget folks please
join me for the moj show facebook live
tonight at 7 p.m
we'll replay the interview and get some
more information so yeah sherry i
i didn't mean to get emotional there but
as i was thinking about this interview
um and learning about this history i
didn't know about black cowboys until i
was in my
mid-20s and i have a cousin who's a
retired professor from howard university
he was there
for 30 years that's when i began to
learn about
it and i thought wow i didn't even know
i thought when i saw
you know black guys and black boys in
cowboy costumes during
uh like halloween i thought oh that's
cute it's not real so that's what
halloween is all about
i never knew it was real until i was an
adult well i tell you oba looks good in
a cowboy hat i know him from the bold
and the beautiful
yeah i did not know he's such a good
looking cowboy too
wow and he was talking about glenn
turman is going to be there he's the
actor
uh from that new netflix movie with
viola davis
all right yeah it i mean just the
celebrities that are going to show up
are going to be amazing of course this
is vegas after all
and people love their pvr yeah they love
their rodeo